how's everything been everything's good
man you know new record new record
enjoying life dabbling into the spanish
world got jay balvin on it
how did it start out did it start out
with quavo giving you that hook and you
were like oh this is crazy yeah so it
actually started yeah like it started
this is like
one of the beats that actually started
with another producer this started with
pharrell an idea from pharrell you know
what i'm saying i called him up got the
files collaborated on it with him and
stuff cuevo killed it i got balvin on it
like around the same time like i heard
it and then um i put my girl anita on it
too you know what i'm saying just to put
she's from brazil put the cherry on top
is she from brazil yeah she's from
brazil have you been there yeah how was
it i was there like i went with her like
a month ago maybe it was crazy were you
are you single no no okay never mind
then
how were the women out there like if you
were single were they anita's great
honestly do i just mean like
brazil as a country brazil's beautiful
country as a young man
brazilian was like my favorite category
to go to on the hub you know
brazilian women are amazing yeah don't
get enough of them in la unfortunately
yeah you're right honestly shout out to
brazil
i got a brazilian myself you know oh you
have a brazilian girl yeah well so then
you know more than anyone yeah kudos to
you sir anita she's great oh anita's
your girl yeah
what the [ __ ]
i had no idea yeah she's lit dude that
was so awkward the fact that i didn't
know that
no she's lit it's it's the shrooms man
it's not the shrooms i just had no
[ __ ] idea man apparently i'm not
tapped in enough no she's dope though i
met her like last year in miami and then
we just kept talking and stuff and then
like started like hanging out a lot and
then like she brought me out of
coachella and then yeah hey what's the
first date like with murder beats in
anita what do you guys do what like how
did you how did you convince her to you
know make things official you know what
i mean because i i too am a caucasian
great guy dating a lovely latin woman
woman and you know so we're kind of
similar we're very similar shout out to
my wife you know what i'm saying um
but you know yeah with some i had to put
some work in
for sure and i'm not i'm not murdered i
just kept seeing her out and stuff and
then just like you know what i'm saying
we kept talking and here and there and
then like kept talking more and more and
more and then just like invite her out
to eat in la and then like what's the
restaurant you take i went to nice guy
nice guy and we went bowling one night
and then yeah bowling in the valley um
[Music]
i don't know like everywhere in
hollywood
oh in hollywood yeah like rented out a
little thing you know oh you're right
you just ran into the whole drone i mean
you know something light it's unlucky
you know something low-key get the whole
[ __ ] bowling alley together no not
the whole one just just the area hello
yeah just a little yeah